hey youtubers is Charlie so we got some
more spider-man homecoming behind the
scenes we'll break that down I'll play
that in a sec but we also may have
learned when the teasers gonna drop so
here we go
actually okay some um simple side semi
off the mini-tramp okay big explosive
side semi kicked out big nice kick out
left foot land you got this
okay yeah got it I got it first
film it as I am glad how's Kristen day
you
Tom Holland doing flips isn't a big a
deal it's super badass but he does this
all the time he even did something like
this in his audition for civil war but
like the Russos like behind the scenes
we're getting him ready and he was like
hey you know should I try and do a flip
or should I try and do some spider-man
moves during the audition and normally
your agents the insurance people that
are standing around making sure nobody
gets hurt or just like just giving him
like the hell no sight and the Russos
were just like hell yeah man go ahead
and do it now the ability to do flips
didn't land him the role the spider-man
but I think that they're working with it
they're like oh he could do all this
other stuff so why don't we work it into
the movies but it is really helpful for
when they do the second part of this
clip the Greenland scenes now if you
don't know what Greenland is they
basically been shooting all the Marvel
movies for the past year or two in the
same place in Atlanta Georgia
within that studio they have a bunch of
different sets depending on what type of
scenes that they film when they film a
big CG action scene like the airport
civil war fight that was like a big CG
scene but they still had to film the
actors in their costumes but then later
they put that into the computer so what
you see on screen like when everyone's
running around and when Spiderman is
going crazy doing all this awesome stuff
it's 100% CG but they still have to have
actors on set to help make it more
realistic when they start doing all the
digital effects so like there's a
physical Spider Man suit that Tom
Holland wears like he's wearing it here
in this picture you can see the upgraded
stark tech web-shooters but when he has
a big fight scene in the movie that'll
be a hundred percent CG suit so like
you'll see scenes where he's walking
around with his mask off where it's not
CG there's like you know a little bit of
CG and then like the really crazy stuff
when they do go full CG so see if you
could spot it when the movie comes out
but they've gotten really good at it
like most people didn't realize that the
airport scene in Civil War was mostly CG
so when the director John Watts posted
this Greenland video he said you know
just got done doing like a really hard
day it means that they were filming one
of the big action scenes of the film
like spider-man versus vulture that is
going to be a hundred percent CG fight
then you have other scenes like where
spider-man is taking villains out in
really comedic ways that might be a
mixture of CG impractical but like
remember that scene in Civil War during
the airport fight where spider-man
I hooked on to Tony Stark and they were
pulling him towards giant man it's going
to be a scene like that only with
vulture like you can imagine vulture
flying through the air
in his flight suit spider-man grabbing
on to him and just getting flung all
over the skies vulture flies around that
will have to be 100% CG but they'll
still have to film a lot of Tom Holland
acting which is where this green land
stuff comes in so even though it doesn't
seem like a big deal that he's just
sitting there like super tired after a
day of filming they were actually
filming one of the biggest things that
you're going to see during the movie now
obviously we don't know exactly what
it's going to be but it will be one of
the big big action scenes of the film
that requires 100% CG so even though Tom
Holland is really acrobatic he might do
a few of his stunts he still has a
stuntman and I know a lot of people have
been wondering who this person is here
who he seems to be hanging out with all
the time off the set now he's credited
as Tom Hollands PA which is basically
personal assistant so he might just be
like a friend of his who also happens to
be an actor and they say okay he can be
your PA and just follow you around so
you have like one of your buddies around
at all times just so you don't get
lonely but a lot of people are wondering
now if this might be Harry Osborn and
they're stealth thing him into the movie
but for now he's just Tom Hollands PA
he's just a friend of his and just
happens to look kind of like an actor
that would totally pull off Harry Osborn
let me know in the comments though what
do you think they were filming in this
big green land set do you think it was
like a big vulture fight and do you
think that they will actually try and
stealth Harry and Norman Osborn into the
film because you can't do spider-man
without Green Goblin at some point but I
can understand why they don't want to go
straight to that in this first film but
that doesn't mean that there's no Norman
Osborn in the MCU when Marvel made the
deal for spider-man you know to share
the character they were sharing all of
the attached IP so there's no spider-man
characters that they cannot put in these
new films but they really are trying to
do something fresh do something with the
spider-man character that hasn't been
done on screen before so I'm not going
to be super pissed if they don't do the
Osborne's right away but I think they'll
get there eventually maybe by the second
film if we don't see him in this but
just reminder there's a new round of the
giveaway I'm giving away a copy of the
Civil War TV
is really like an Amazon giftcard for
the value of the blu-ray there's all
kinds of deleted scenes I'll be doing a
video for it next week after it drops
but all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video they're not quite done filming
spider-man homecoming so they'll
probably more stuff like this from
behind the scenes they'll keep teasing
stuff out because I don't think we're
going to see the first trailer at least
until the Super Bowl next year but I
have heard a rumor that they're going to
drop that Comic Con footage in October
it's just a rumor but it plays like a
funny remix of a high school class
schedule in September October is when
people are back in school so it makes
sense that they would tease a high
school film right as everyone is getting
back into school so really big trailer
probably not coming til the Super Bowl
along with guardians of the galaxy - but
we might see a small teaser in October
no idea what day that would be just
don't be surprised if your spidey sense
is tingling all over October but what's
going to happen next is is they had like
a big convention over the weekend they
reveal some really cool stuff about the
flash TV show so I'll be doing a video
for that next while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for the
Thor Ragnarok Comic Con footage and you
can click here for the Civil War
bloopers thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight